When did you realize that beaver
would delicious? Not till after I,
I think I know the first one when I was
in the first one I ever ate while I was
in community college,
I still tell people about the beaver
that you cook for us in Wisconsin and how
good it is. And they look at you
sideways. And Mike, I'm telling you, man,
it was like the most delicious pot
roast I've ever had was fantastic. Yeah,
it was really good. There's even
stories about early on with the, um,
when early explorers,
we're in this country,
they had a difficult time getting phished
sometimes and beaver were approved for
the Lenten meal because they were aquatic.
Wow.
So on Fridays when you had to have,
like,
when you're supposed to
have your meat free day,
you were allowed to eat beaver meat
because they were a water animal.
It was a very popular food
item. You follow what I'm
saying? Yeah, yeah, yeah. No,
I get it. The first one, the first ones
we ate, I had started reading about,
I'd always read narratives,
stories about the mountain men. Um,
meaning like when I say mountain in like
a very specific thing like a, you know,
a rocky mountain beaver trapper who was
sandwiched between who is sandwiched in
time between the end of the Lewis and
Clark expedition and the collapse of the
beaver market in the 1840 [inaudible].
It's like a very like finite period
of time was what a mountain man was
explained to people how
big the beaver market is.
Cause this is going to blow people's
minds. Well, America's first, you know,
asked her,
John Jacob Astor,
like the beaver market made
America's first millionaires.
His fortunes came from being a beef or
trader, the richest men in the country.
Their money came from beavers. Yeah.
And he was in on the business end of it.
He wasn't in on the trap
and then have it right.
He was in on the habits the for companies.
Yeah.
The big for our company when we bought,
think about like this,
how big it was for us to do the Louisiana
purchase and to buy that chunk of land.
Uh,
when Lewis and Clark came out,
part of their mandate was to suss out
to potential for the trade and beaver
hides. Wow. It'd be like buying something
I'd wanna know about oil and gas. Right.
You don't know. It can be
justified this through oil and gas,
they're looking to justify it through
trade and beaver hides. Now also,
there was also language about that
they might find out about whether wooly
mammoth through existing
out there as well.
So there was like some confusion
about what was going on. Wow.
They really thought that woolly
mammoths were still alive.
Jefferson was interested in that stuff
because he had, he had been to some areas,
uh,
he had some familiarity and Ben to some
areas with these large bones and he was
puzzled. Bottom. He was wondering if
this wasn't some, if it may be in fact,
was not a, an extinct species, but was
somehow living in the American west still.
How hard is it to real historians
like people, not historian,
popular historians really love
to make a big deal out of that.
Cause it's so weird, but it
wasn't like, Hey, let's buy the,
let's do the Louisiana purchase
transaction because of the possibility of
locating ma'am. It's, I think it was
like an idea that was floated around.
People see it in a,
they,
people such as me see it and
perhaps overemphasize what it meant,
but it was an idea that was out there.
The beaver trade stuff was
certainly a big factor.
Another thing I was reading about recently
that to point out to your, to your, uh,
that you might think is interesting is
that people have this idea of Lewis and
Clark going into this unspoiled
uncontacted landscape.
I was recently reading a piece by a
historian who is talking about at the time
of Lewis and Clark headed
out into the great plains.
There were native Americans living on
the great plains who had been to Europe
and met the King of France and
returned back to the great plains
well year.
They,
they went out in the early 18
hundreds so they were out in 1804 wow.
You got to,
if you imagine the time from the time
in the 15 hundreds when the Spanish,
right,
we're poking around
and come like corn auto,
right.
Coming up from Mexico into the Great
Plains Cabeza de Vaca being shipwrecked,
wrong,
the Gulf coast and people pushing up into
these areas that was hundreds of years
prior.
Like the distance that separates,
imagine the distance has separated Lewis
and Clark from the first Europeans who
were doing activities in and around the
great plains is like the distance and
time that separates us from Lewis
and Clark more so. Right? Yeah.
It's the distance and time that
separates us from the declaration of
independence. It was like a long history
of people messing around crazy. However.
Yeah,
but think about too,
like Lewis and Clark were encountering
people who had horses, right? Right.
And those horses had been,
was horsemen traded up.
So that's just like a side note.
This idea of eating beaver.
So I got from reading
about the mountain men,
I got interested in decide cause he's
always see like anytime you read about
mountain and you're always going to find
the part where the author talks about
how much mountain men liked beaver tail.
Um,
and the first people that tried it and
be retail, it was around when I was,
I was in community college
at the time and my brothers,
I remember stuck a B retail in
the oven for awhile and cooked it.
And they report it back to me that like
whatever it is they're talking about. Uh,
isn't that like there must
be some other explanation.
We beavertail yeah, yeah, we ate it.
And Wisconsin, we have a, there's a,
there's a hotter, there's like pictures
and an explanation of how to prepare,
how to actually prepare a beaver tail
mountain man style in the meat and your
fish and game cookbook. It wasn't
bad. It was just blend. It's just fat.
It's fat.
So after that we started thinking that
when they say the mountain and like
beaver tail, we thought it have meant
they like rump based the high end quarter.
So we started when we went.
I would catch beavers. Um,
I'd be careful when skin and
I'm just not get the caster.
The beavers have two large glands on
the inside of their legs. They're like,
talk to him there. What it looks
like if you lay a beaver on its back,
talked to kind of on either side of its,
uh,
of its like if it's a male
like talk to you, your side,
it's penis or either side
Clayco you'll, you'll see a, uh,
not call a couple like vent. You'll see
these, these glands that are the size of,
I don't know if you make like a,
if you take your index finger
and your thumb and make a circle,
there's like a gland on each
side called the cast or gland.
There's oil gland in there.
They used to use it for perfume.
It still has value today.
It's used for a wide variety of things.
The smells beautiful.
If you ever walking on a stream bank and
you smell like a strange perfume smell,
it's usually be recast her. Wow.
Smells great, tastes like shit.
Tastes like you're eating. Like you rubbed
roses or something all over your food.
So start figuring out like to,
to skin them and be very careful not
to get the cast or on your knife,
forget the cast or on your hands.
And then we would just take the meat and
put it in crock pots with potatoes and
onions and stuff and just
cook them down in a crock pot.
You could pick them and it was like roast
beef. So when I started eating that,
but I still then later I realized that
it read all their accounts of how people
are prepared be retail. And if you
take the tail like the Scaly ass tail,
and it really should be from a fall beaver
cause the tail will be twice as thick
in the fall than it is in the spring.
They're of Macy aided in the spring. Um,
take the tail and skewered on a stick
and put it next to a fire where the skin
starts to bubble and boil away.
And pretty soon you can just peel that
skin away and was hiding under there.
Is the,
the the best equivalent,
like the best equivalent or point
of comparison I can think of.
We'll beat it. Just, it's
like if you had a really,
like imagining you're getting
a grass fed steak, right,
but still has that fatty gristle on it.
It's just made up of that gristle
like what a lot of people would
trim away from a steak and eat.
That's what's inside that beaver tail.
But people eat these individuals that
were doing this for fat starved eating
such lean meat all the time.
I think they loved it because
here's like a chunk of fat. Yeah.
Okay.
And they had ready access to it cause
they're catching them to make a living.
And if you're just eating the meat,
there's no fat on the meat.
And so they would compliment it
with just eating the beavertail fat.
And I'll often tell people about, and I
even gave some to the, there's like a, uh,
culinary arts institute and I gave
some chefs that stuff and everyone,
the eats it points out,
there's not that it tastes so fantastic,
but it's just like really interesting to
try and eat it, the fat from the tail.
And it's like you got to
put yourself in position.
You've probably been in this too,
where if you're,
especially if you're out
hunting and eating, you know,
like freeze dried food or not eating great
and you're just exerting yourself all
day all the time, how you're doing what
you want to eat changes a lot. Yeah.
And you, the level of appetite
you have is off the charts. Yeah.
And so just like to eat like a big
slab of fat, it'd be very excited.
Was appealing to people.
Yeah.